all right welcome back to em you sure
abduction
my name's piggy I'm excited let's go
piggy pay
what alright let's go let's go yeah I'm
put and put here you go Alice Lee why
you gonna lose all right ye son be in
the lag I'm a dead pig you got a problem
now there's some problem okay
welcome back to ah [ __ ] don't close the
door
sorry piggy I mean I'm piggy but quick
yeah yeah yeah I cannot feel like I'm
funny today
welcome back to some amnesia abduction
part 8 right over there we were gonna go
here and I got take it with me yay I'm
back and my ass is flapping in the air
yeah alright let's pick him up like this
sorry sorry piggy no it's okay scream
I'm playing yeah yeah it's good I'm
excited yeah wow wow wow don't scream
piggy
monster can you oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I
get excited or something you should know
that uh I'm trying to find a way out I
don't remember where I came from and it
seems that a lot of people are upset
about the fact that um
I really can't locate uh well murder are
you through me Rumpy
I mean I'm piggy what I really can't
find the [ __ ] exit even though I try
it on okay piggy where is he I'm gonna
leave piggy here for a second all right
no it's cool it's cool it's cool I
understand I really need financing but I
like
I don't know maybe it's here it's so
difficult when it's dark
I can't free on it oh here it is where
do I put pity I'll leave piggy there for
a minute and we're gonna go help her
here hmm
and I have Ezio women yes until I find
safar no at least
dancing arm table
yeah yeah 316 I mean okay so you guys
suggested that I took water from the
fountain let's see if that works if it
doesn't work then you guys are gonna
look like it I got like five messages
about it it's okay I have suggestion
maybe that's seal
let's stay there ah
all right they'll have to do Betsy likes
to show his crotch to you guys
yeah have some nah see nah I got like
five messages I got you're an idiot
Boober Boober water from the fountain I
cannot rely yeah Syria now that means
pretty much item trust you that means
pretty much I don't really know where to
go or what two for two I don't trust
anyone in this game uh but that was
level right I thought something about a
library that I miss I guess we can go
there but it's all dark scary I don't
and then I have to go and get that dirt
bits fire there
they're good sire I won't try that
there fits fire so weird
let's go to the storage are you with me
Ezio he wants to show his genitals
how big is back at least
barrels all right not what seriously
there was supposed to be a lever here
somewhere I swear on my pants
oh yeah we took the key and then we went
and yeah right yeah yeah yeah I'm a
genius - then we went in here
and it was like a monster was like where
and there was a deadly shovels and stuff
but they're not deadly right now
I don't know where to go
and be here where is it that big
where is it oh yeah that's there I've
heard admit in here like climate it's
hard to orient when you can't see what
you're going I'm just saying oh yeah
I've been here to signal yes that's
where I came maybe over there supposed
to be I found the lever yes yes but I
all fix more pings piggy you have
cousins yay yay
I'm not piggy um I'm Julius yes Julius
that's my name
you got a problem my name you think I
named pig King I don't even know what
I'm talking about yeah you see this is
ever I can't believe you missed it
I drew choo here right where do we put
the lever that's the question
I think it's in this room
look how dark it is holy crap where did
we put this lever in your mom's never
mind maybe here that helps actually I
feel much better
but still know where to place alone
where's piggy I Miss Piggy Miss Piggy
I was seriously I love her why is it so
difficult when it's hard that's what she
said
come on
maybe there's nothing about this lever
yeah there it is syrtis I'm a genius
but I won't piggy with me yes I need
piggy
baby not in here
where's piggy where's the where's piggy
piggy piggy piggy piggy piggy piggy
not that Julius guy is a douchebag
I left him here didn't I found a legend
there oh well all right
Julie else it's me all right no wrongful
face
I'm piggy I'm excited look how excited I
am
I'll flop in my butt in your face um
you're like I pretty you like my burden
in your face mm-hmm I know you're like I
know you like it mm-hmm
actually I don't like it please don't do
that all right I'll just float over heat
I'm excited I'm excited let's go let's
go to the place where the lever was I'm
floating around cuz I'm a dead pig
mm-hmm
I'm a snake I'm a snake you thought I
was big I thought I was big no I'm sneak
look almost like I think it was in here
yeah I'm a snake I'm excited yeah yeah
snakes
whoa did you see that backflip holy [ __ ]
that was how the heck did I do that I
made a [ __ ] backflip and jumped on
him okay here it is are you scared you
scared you scared escaped escapee I
understand all right you back it up with
stupid [ __ ] you did like two seconds
oh sorry babe
no I'm not p.m. please
I'm a snake I must pick a snake
I know you like I know you like I know
you excited you see that teeny bug pity
you see you pick it hey don't touch my
bed I'll push you backwards all right
sorry sorry piggy I mean I'll just call
you piggy because it's complicated I'll
leave you here first thing all right I
need a vote around and [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] just leave me all I'll
leave you some bread so it's okay you go
everyone is happy huh
but there's got to be something else
that sound how it goes back right away
mmm there's definitely something in here
I'm just gonna perform some surgery on
piggy hey sorry pee no it's cool yeah
pocket pocket pocket
yes yes yes why are you so excited
why boy okay but now we know what to do
at least I think that will leave piggy
here for now no it's cool just leave me
I'm a snake I'll play here my sexy
position my sexy position now I'll wait
for Miss Piggy to show good
so now we can take water from the
fountain oh [ __ ] I need your picking I
just kidding
I need your piggy I need you I need you
I need you I need you oh I'm scared too
you know I might be a pig in a snake but
I get scared too
alright let's go open the lever but
don't okay don't open it right now
though I said Oh No
okay let's go let's go I'll I'll take
this one for me hey monster monster oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay piggy you're on your own
am i doing
uh-uh don't look at him don't look at
him Oh Oh piggy do it for me uh I hope
we can to break that door piggy is a
[ __ ] hero
Savannah left me piggy is a [ __ ] hero
he's fighting with him or making out is
it cheating on me pig is cheating on me
piggy what are you doing ah ah [ __ ]
leave already
he may be son but I don't trust him ah
okay
oh good
it's don't look at
pretty I would you know that we didn't
make other anything it's cool like he
wanted to do stuff with me and I was
like no no I'm wicked bad
I don't want it but he like touched me
stuff anyway
it's so keeping hands I know but I want
to be I want it to work between us so I
wanna I want to be sure that you know
you know don't you think I'm sexy
mm-hm and I'm floating around on the
floor like this do you think I'm sexy I
think I'm pretty sexy it's dark now you
know what that means it's makeup time
come here and kiss me Petey here's a
little kick no I don't want it I know
his lips have been all over you but come
on Petey come on he just touched me a
little I might like a little but you
know you know my heart's on for you I
should stop like I'm [ __ ] I'm leaving
your piggy you cheated on me
no come on Petey come back to me energy
learn because sexy eyes go back to the
water fountain thing I think it's this
way
holy [ __ ] I found the way it's you I
thought I bet she knows
come on it's pretty [ __ ] [ __ ]
that you can't use a glass jar to get
water but you can use a bucket of wood I
mean a glass jar would be more effective
just saying that's thing holy [ __ ] I
need to go soon
yellow asked me what it feels like
staring at the sky so Vendela telling
Kurt Russell homie this ain't real life
I'll be making good on my promises
honesty is pop it in slot of it is
listen but I realize I could be better
than I was light on my feet
cooking up this all when we fire up the
P